I want you to think about two words
these are two words that are searched on
Google regularly one word is money the
other word is happy now which of these
two words you think is search more on
Google money or happy here's a numbers
money comes out with 2.5 billion results
happy comes out with 2.8 six billion
results why more people are thinking
about being happy than getting money now
if that's the question if that's the
case why are so few people are happy in
the world and there's so many bitter you
know people who are not able to enjoy
themselves right so this is a very
common question that's asked how to be
happy so today I wanted to explain this
in a way that maybe makes sense to you
and I will promise you one thing here's
one thing I guarantee you I will
guarantee I'm gonna say word to you in
this video about happiness now you
probably don't hear maybe you've never
heard it linked to happiness and we'll
cover that here with you so for me when
I think about myself for many years I'm
running and gun and I'm trying to figure
out my own life I'm trying to figure out
what I want to do and I'm not fulfilled
and I'm wondering why I'm not fulfilled
and I'm asking myself how come this
guy's got this and how come this person
is doing this maybe do I need to go out
and become a business owner do I go
become this person dog will become that
person do I become what do I do
so for longest time I'm trying to figure
out a way to fit into society and to fit
into the world I was not happy until I
figure this thing out I believe the most
important quality to being happy is
being aligned aligned what I mean by
align align to me is when you what you
say and what you do is aligned you're
happy when what you believe and how you
act is aligned you're happy let me give
you an explanation here what I mean by
this I want you to look at that look at
this chart here and you got two
different areas you're looking at okay
two different areas
you're looking at on the left it shows
you how many hours one works so we got
20 hours 40 hours 60 hours 80 hours 100
hours a week on URI its goals no goals
small goals average goals big goals so
this represents your wants your desires
your goals this represents your behavior
your action your effort fair enough
goals effort in the middle is happiness
this represents happiness when you're
aligned with the amount of effort you're
putting in with the size of your goal
let me give you an explanation what I
mean by this for instance let's just say
I have big goals I have very big goals I
want to have 10 million dollars in cash
and I want to drive Ferraris and I want
to have a big 15,000 square-foot home
and I'm going to go see the world I'm
gonna have a lot of respect I want
people to know me I want influence so I
have massive goals so I'm hearing goals
but I'm only willing to work 20 hours a
week so this is Ryan Doug this is a
channel person who is clear on what they
want but they're lazy you won't be happy
here now let me give you another one
let's just say we have somebody who
works two jobs you're working eighty
five hours a week but they have no goals
in life they're here you're also not
happy the goal is to be as close to here
as possible
now you take somebody who has average
goals what's average goals I want to
make a quarter million dollar your
income average goals I want to be a good
husband a good father a good mom a good
wife a good entrepreneur a good business
person a good exec and whatever it is
but I want to be good these are my
average goals and I'm willing to work 60
hours a week just what this person is
very happy because their effort is
aligned with their goals when these two
are aligned you have happiness the same
thing goes with you know fitments this
doesn't have to be just finances if
let's just say how big goals I'm gonna
have a six-pack but also on a cheesecake
I'm not happy I'm bitter because what
I'm saying what I want and what I'm
doing is not aligned I am NOT
see everything in life is about
alignment if you ever think about
moments in your life that you really
didn't like yourself or you had internal
conflict it's because you were not
living an aligned life whether it's
business marriage relationship finance
health it doesn't matter the more
aligned you are the better you do in
every aspect of your business so now
what does this mean if we want to go
even deeper what if I'm looking at this
for myself and I'm mentoring people
because I'm regularly mentoring
thousands of people so how do i mentor
somebody when I look at this who is
fixable who is not let me make this
thing clear here
somebody who is on this side it is very
difficult to get somebody to go from
this category to this category why
because they're not willing to work hard
I can't do anything about work ethic
there's nothing I can do anything about
your work ethic but I can very easily
get somebody who is not clear on what
they want but they're doing effort I can
easily get them to get big goals by
asking questions from them and seeing
what they want then you're happy because
they're aligned with their effort and
their goals all they need is somebody to
give them direction on what they really
want out of life
many times it's simply somebody who's
willing to sit down with your knee cap
to kneecap and have a conversation with
you and ask you questions are you going
to tell them what ticks eventually when
you figure out what takes and a moment
this this this field I want to do this
and you got the effort it's just a time
and effort so this this could be you
you're working very hard maybe you're
going to be having some you know average
goals and you're working 60 hours a week
but if you want to speed it up well if
you want to speed it up you got average
goals for work 80 hours a week it's
going to come faster now obviously it's
efficient time but it's going to come
faster now let me tell you one story
here that maybe will help you out to
illustrate this much better the other
night I'm putting my oldest son to sleep
Tico and I had just come back from
Harvard and when I was in Harvard I was
in Boston we visited John FK Kay's a
presidential libraries what we did write
really nice place really neat place and
we walk into this place and you know
which is
fascinating you'll see the video when it
comes at a Harvard experience that Paul
is working on heavily when that comes
out but when when that video comes out
you'll see one thing here's what you'll
see we go in there just an incredible
amount of stories and then when we're
coming out you know we go to the store
and all of a sudden you know I buy one
item another item another light all of
sudden you see the guys like I want one
of these I'm one of these I feel like a
kid in a candy store
$1,300 later just find a bunch of
nonsense stuff that I felt inspired and
I sent a bunch of yet but I got three
things I've got three shirts one for my
daughter
she's a four months old one for my
three-year-old son who just turned three
and one for my oldest son they all say
future president okay so I got these
three shirts I'm excited future
president from JFK president's
Presidential Library and I come back and
I got Tico and Dylan this book about
presidents how they were when they were
kids
okay so Tico says daddy can you read me
this book tonight I said no problem so
we go upstairs and he's laying in bed
and so we start reading the book and we
finished the whole book together all
presidents from the first one to the
last one just fascinating stories what
they like that's kids what they were
like etc etc so he's laying right next
to me okay now watch this this is a four
year old kid I'm whispering to him our
daily affirmations I I
Patrick Gabriel Ben David Patrick a
bourbon David will one day one day be a
be a great leader great leader high five
okay every day both of them and we do
that affirmation and then I say to you I
just want you know if you ever want to
become a president guess what you can if
you choose to become a president just
make sure you make your money first so
later on when you run you're not
controlled by people that are putting
money into your campaign you're free to
choose the way you want to lead people
okay 30 seconds he's not saying anything
to me Chum thinking he's either is sleep
knocked out or he's thinking he's a
thinker my four-year-old son is a
thinker 30 seconds later this is what he
says to me listen what this kid says to
me he says dad I suggest that he says I
don't want to be a president can I just
be a kid right now
this is a four-year-old kid he's
challenging his dad he's saying that I
just want to be a kid right now you know
what he's really saying don't put this
kind of pressure on me I don't want to
be a president right now I just want to
be a kid and I sit down I say that
absolutely can be a kid I said look at
your daddy your daddy's not a president
and he's doing okay but if you ever want
to you can I'm just telling you I
believe in you
he says okay daddy but can I be a kid
right now I said yes I said you want a
wrestle yes we turn on the lights and we
wrestle for five minutes together and he
went to sleep right what does this mean
to you you're listening to st. Pat I
don't wish to moral this story here's
what the moral story is as a mentor
leading people for many years I try to
force people in a box until I realized
they don't want to be in this thing they
don't want to be in this thing what am I
going to do force this person to get in
here and fastest way to create an
enemies to do what is to force somebody
to do something they don't want to do
that's why people hate taxes it's force
there are certain things that people
hate because it's force choice is a
different story
give me choices what are my choices so
for many years I would look at someone
else a man this guy can go places now
part of a leadership is being able to
see something on people that others
don't see you got to do that you got to
do that so I this is what I do when I
look at people that I'm mentoring now I
simply ask on what their desires and
goals are once I know what their desires
and goals are for me to mentor this
person then I ask for their effort if
their effort is here and I help their
desires and goals go here I'm personally
working with this person because their
desire is high and they're willing to
put the effort I'll come and give you
the direction I'll come and mentor you
that formula has worked for me because
now I choose who I want to work with who
has the high desires that wants the
goals and is willing to put the effort
my son very clearly said that I don't
want to be a present it's totally fine I
want to be a kid all good no problem
let's be a kid boy let's max up being a
kid right now let's wrestle let's max up
being a kid right now what do you want
I want to draw on the wall so you get
these markers that they can draw on the
one in the water you know you can clean
what do you want to do no problem
okay but happy expectation of you sound
three things what is it daddy whatever
you do you lead I don't care what you do
you leave the situation number two
whatever you do respect people okay and
whatever you do you better keep getting
better pops I don't care what you do I
just want us to improve this is what we
do as a bad David family okay daddy
so keep getting better did you respect
did you leave the situation yes all the
other stuff you want to be a lawyer
go be a lawyer you want to be what do
you want to do all good but those things
have to be aligned for to take place so
as you're listening to this and you're
wondering Pat are you really telling me
happinesses alignment yes it is
happiness is alignment you want to test
it out for yourself think about it this
way you have a driven a car and you're
driving your car and you take your hands
off the wheel and all of a sudden the
car starts doing what going to the left
what do you need to do you need what
kind of a test you need an alignment
test now why do you need an alignment
test because if you don't get an
alignment test and you don't put your
hands on the steering what's going to
happen to the car you're going to crash
the car so one you need to go to the
shop and have somebody align your tires
so the next time you take your hands off
the type to see if the cars align it
goes straight it's easier saves you
miles per gallon it gives you better
tires you save your tires your tires may
last longer there's many benefits for
the car if they're aligned the same with
life the more you're aligned with these
two the happier you are on by the way
the closer you're gonna get your dreams
and goals the more you're gonna be able
to maximize your life your dream what
you want to do because some people say
what if somebody's right here they don't
work hard they want to live with mommy
and daddy and have zero clothes but
they're happy how is that even possible
because they're aligned they're aligned
what if I'm a kid I don't want to do
anything I just want to play video games
what do you want to do with your life
nothing but they're happy they're
aligned then the question doesn't come
become about happiness then the question
comes about how big you think
you're a small thinker you're a big
thinker maybe someone needs to challenge
you now that's a whole different
conversation and for somebody to want to
increase their goals I think this part
of it also has a little bit to do about
what you want but also has a little bit
to do with how you want to give back
there are seven billion people live in
this world and all of us have many
different sets of talents and abilities
right yours are going to be different
than mine
and I think in a way I think in a way we
are given these talents to do something
with them okay and I think sometimes
someone's going to come in and they're
going to say listen why don't you use
that talent that you have to get into
sales why don't you have that talent
that problem-solving skills that you
have munching into business but why
don't you use those gifts that you have
with numbers when you're so good once
you get your financial services well why
don't you use this you can read people
so aren't you going to management once
you go into leadership well you're so
good at reading people your intuition is
always so good you need to get you I
never thought about that I never thought
of inspiration inspiration inspiration
goals effort boom happiness this makes
sense I mean I'm hoping this is makes
sense making sense to you because you
can write a whole book about this and
title the book alignment or the key to
happiness and talk alignment in the book
and it'll make sense if you take this
test now for some of you guys now how do
you take your alignment test very simple
here's your alignment test right on your
goals on a lab take a sheet of paper
very simple put a line vertical and
horizontal goes on one side action on
the other side so remember okay you got
once these are goals on one side
whatever wants what are your desires
what are your goals on this side is
behavior action effort separate them
then answer this question if a goal is I
want to lose 20 pound your action your
behavior how aligned is it your goal
rated from 0 to 10 so if it's 3 does it
cause you bitterness are you happy about
your health there's a reason why you're
not happy about your health because
you're not aligned same with your
business same with your relationship
same with you cliff you do this test
almost always 100% of the time it's work
for me anytime I've caught myself being
a little bit frustrated or bitter or
annoyed or you know I feel like things
are unfair et cetera et cetera now from
you know sums happening to me while I'm
going away from having a positive
attitude I'm losing it for like a second
I gotta go back to my alignment test Pat
let's do the alignment test what are you
unhappy about it's not the world it's
not the world you control alignment tell
me about the alignment situation that we
have got that yeah that's what I need I
got it I'll fix it
here's what we need to do boom boom boom
happy at peace aligned so my challenge
to you as you watch this video you may
need to watch it twice because I kind of
want to do pretty fast cuz I got a
conference call here with Kelly and we
got a National Conference so I've got to
do it a couple thousand people but I
wanted to make sure I got this episode
out to you because again common question
Pat why is it seem like you're so
comfortable in your skin what is the key
to being comfortable in your skin what
is the key to being happy what is the
key to become all this stuff that you
keep hearing about and everybody wants
to give their own you know the key to
helping as hard work with its alignment
okay its alignment test this and see if
it proves you wrong I can tell you it's
going to prove you right it's prove me
right and it's proved many people that
I've mentored over the years right and
once you can figure out those two things
to be on the same page you will get the
highest highest highest or level of
return on your talent and your time
possible Mari let's get this pillow here
you know it's crazy
by the time I've shown this to you we've
crossed 100,000 subs but that Desmond we
don't need more subscribers and when we
started using this pillow I think we
were at 41,000 subs like three four
months ago that we're now for 100,000
subs which is exciting and if you
haven't already watched a video about a
special gift I'm giving back to all my
fans everybody all the value Tanner's
out there stay tuned we're going to give
something to invite three people to come
and spend some one-on-one time with me
you can probably email or visit Patrick
video vidcom to find out more
information about the sport email
marketing at Patrick
some of you may watch this video you're
from that two years from now by that
time it's already over with but we're
doing that for us reaching 100,000
selves on value teaming with YouTube
which is very very exciting and it
happened just because of you and many of
you went out of your way to getting as
many people to subscribe as possible if
you've got any question about alignment
post your questions and your comments on
the bottom thanks for watching take
everybody bye-bye